hey guys Lucy here with a less than
cheery gamespot news update for you just
one week after EverQuest developer sony
online entertainment broke off from Sony
and rebranded itself the daybreak game
company the developer has confirmed job
losses at two of its American offices in
a statement the company said as part of
a strategic decision to rationalize the
business daybreak game company announced
today that it will eliminate positions
in both its San Diego and Austin studios
this alignment of resources better
positions the newly independent studio
for future growth opportunities and
developments including delivering on its
legacy of making top online games and
establishing a solid foundation for
future multi-platform success these
reductions will not affect the operation
of current games and the company will
continue on its mission to partner with
its player community to drive the future
and push the boundaries of online gaming
a source called kotaku that daybreakers
cutting jobs in an effort to become
profitable so nice old SOE two new
york-based private investment firm
columbus nova last week for an
undisclosed sum among those affected by
the layoffs was veteran EverQuest
producer David Georgeson he confirmed
his departure from the studio in a post
on Twitter as part of the spinoff from
Sony daybreak will now make games for
xbox platforms including the Xbox one
although no specific projects have been
announced and all SOE games will
continue on their current path of
development and operation some of day
breaks in development games include h1z1
EverQuest next and EverQuest next
landmark as well as continued support
for planetside 2 everquest 2 and DC
Universe Online Sony Online
Entertainment was founded in nineteen
ninety-five starting with the name Sony
interactive studios America and in 1998
became SOE it was originally tasked with
making playstation only games though in
recent years it has focused specifically
on free to play PC games best of luck to
all those affected by the layoffs for
all the latest make sure you stay tuned
to gamespot com
you